it's never a good idea to get drunk on
the job these actors learned that the
hard way when their inebriated Antics
cost them valuable screen time
Sasha biren Cohen is a comedian
recognized and sometimes not recognized
for his outrageous characters that he
drops into real world scenarios the
English star hosted his own television
series da Ali G's show and is starred in
a collection of dynamic movies from the
children's picture Madagascar to the
feature film adaptation of Les
Miserables of course the comedian's most
iconic moments have stemmed from his
satirical movies like Borat and Bruno
Cohen has made a career out of putting
himself into character and not breaking
no matter how terrible or dangerous
things get unsurprisingly his dedication
has put him in some scary situations one
of his most hilarious stories comes from
a segment where Borat was attending a
wine tasting unable to fake it the actor
who admittedly does not drink often was
forced to drink more than his fair share
of booze Cohen admitted to Conan O'Brien
I think I had 21 glasses of wine I said
the place I must go toilet I went in
there and they came in after a while
because I didn't return I passed out in
the toilet thankfully the persistent
comedian managed to wake up in character
without missing a beat I woke up and I
just looked them and I said I want more
wine
clerk star Jason Muse owes an entire
career to his good friend co-star and
director Kevin Smith after he first
joined the celebrated director as the
Jay to A Silent Bob Muse made
appearances and nearly every one of
Smith's subsequent films unfortunately
Muse has admitted that he was wildly
irresponsible when he started portraying
the foul-mouthed drug dealer Jay a
character that was written explicitly
for him Muse opened up to Metro saying I
was either drinking or smoking the whole
time they had to send me home sometimes
I was drinking Blackberry Brandy I
passed out on the floor I was so drunk I
was slurring during a scene with Randall
so they had to send me home thankfully
Muse gained better self-control for
Smith's sophomore projects Mall Rats he
elaborated I didn't even drink or
anything they had Seth Green on standby
in case I didn't get the audition all
these years later Muse has turned his
life around after recovering from
addiction the actor has become a
responsible father any maintains a close
yet sober relationship with his old
friend Kevin Smith the two most recently
appeared together in clerks 3 which
brought the original characters stories
full circle
inarguably one of the most famous movies
in history it defined the summer
blockbuster became one of the highest
grossing films of its era kicked off
Steven Spielberg's career and is still
imitated by genre movies today however
what many fans don't know is that one of
the movie's most famous scenes had to be
reshot because one of the film's leading
actors was inebriated beyond
comprehension in a 36th anniversary
interview with Ain't It Cool
discussed much of the behind the scenes
workings of Jaws including some secrets
about the famous Indianapolis speech
delivered by Robert Shaw another thing
about a shark
lifeless eyes black eyes like a doll's
eye
Spielberg said of the scene we shot it
twice the first time we attempted to
shoot it Robert came over to me and said
you know Stephen all three of these
characters have been drinking and I
think I could do a much better job in
this speech if you let me actually have
a few drinks before I do the speech and
die on wisely gave him permission
reportedly Shaw went more than a bit
overboard Spielberg elaborated I had two
cameras on the scene and we never got
through the scene he was just too far
gone thankfully the actor was better
prepared the next morning delivering the
momentous scene as shown in the film in
just a few takes the 2013 comedy drama
drinking buddies is a unique film that
was reportedly championed by alcohol
infused inhibition starring Olivia Wilde
Jake Johnson and Anna Kendrick the
dialogue was almost entirely improvised
with the actors only being required to
hit certain plot points along the way
meanwhile the film takes place mostly in
a brewery swimming with beer that the
actors would start drinking early in the
day while told off camera with Sam Jones
we were hammered the entire movie
because it was real beer because beer on
that set was cheaper than water it makes
sense that many of the off the cuff
scenes fueled by an abundance of
brewskis would be unusable but none
struggled more to make the unique film
work than Anna Kendrick the Pitch
Perfect star told vulture I was like I'm
super drunk right now and so as soon as
the take was over I had to announce to
everybody that I was drunk at work I was
horrified by the idea that I was going
to be the next Troublesome star who got
drunk and started flipping over tables
or whatever I just tried to sit quietly
until I sobered up Mario and Luigi might
be played by Chris Pratt and Charlie Day
nowadays but there was a time when the
iconic characters were confoundingly
portrayed by Bob Hoskins and John
leguizama in 1993 the live-action Super
Mario Bros film was released to A Chorus
of scathing reviews and its stars were
inclined to agree with them Bob Hoskins
who brought everyone's favorite red
suited plumber to life considered the
film a massive disappointment the one
regret he had about his career before
his death in 2014. he complained to the
guardian it had a husband and wife team
directing whose arrogance had been
mistaken for talent after so many weeks
their own agent told them to get off the
set meanwhile John Leguizamo who played
the one and only Luigi has since
revealed how much drinking took place on
the set the failing movie and alcohol
infused Talent resulted in many mishaps
during production famously Leguizamo
accidentally accelerated a vehicle too
abruptly causing a sliding vandor to
break hoskin's hand even further Hoskins
later told Entertainment Tonight that he
was stabbed multiple times electrocuted
and nearly drowned during the making of
Super Mario Brothers Mamma Mia
by all accounts the late comedic actor
John Candy was a class act on the sets
of his many films however the Uncle Buck
star did get in some trouble in one of
the most unlikely projects splash the
Tom Hanks romantic comedy about falling
in love with the mermaid was the first
film produced under Disney's Touchstone
brand and was concocted by up-and-coming
director Ron Howard still as the
Director would recount in Josh gad's
YouTube series reunited apart there was
one day of filming that almost never
made it onto the big screen and it's all
Jack Nicholson's fault Howard
recollected John totally professional
guy but he's late one day he finally
pulls up and kind of rolls out of the
car and he says Ron I'm so sorry I'm
drunk here's what happened I'm telling
you the truth I'm at the bar and Jack
Nicholson's at the bar Jack Nicholson
knew my name Ron the Allure of sharing a
drink with Jack Nicholson was simply too
tempting an offer for candy to pass up
with filming continuing on Splash the
next morning King Andy paid a price for
his late night run-in with Nicholson
Howard remembered him saying I never
went to bed Ron I never went to bed
Unforgettable for his time hosting
weekend update on Saturday Night Live
comedian Norm Macdonald went on to have
a successful career in film and
television before his untimely passing
however the actor's first appearance in
a major Motion Picture started on wobbly
footing as he joined fellow SNL Alum
Adam Sandler as the best friend to the
titular Billy Madison the two actors
reminisced about their time making the
cult classic comedy during an appearance
on Conan particularly once seen by the
pool Sandler recalled I say my line and
I think I did it very well and I'm like
let me see how Norm ping-ponged this
line back so there was a little bit of a
delay and I was like old Norm likes to
take his time then I'm waiting longer
and going wow he's really milking this
one in a few more seconds later I
noticed old Norm was sleeping MacDonald
was quick to joke that he was taking his
method acting a bit too seriously well
they wanted me to play a drunk right and
so I said uh you've got some booze once
a budding star in Hollywood Shia LaBeouf
became more than just the kid from Even
Stevens when he starred in the first few
outings of the Transformers franchise
unfortunately after multiple legal
issues and struggles with addiction Le
buff is better recognized today as a
movie Wild Card the actor and filmmaker
has been at the center of multiple
rumors concerning his onset Behavior
including an altercation with Alec
Baldwin somewhat surprisingly though it
was LaBeouf's first steps outside the
big budget Productions of Transformers
and Indiana Jones in the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull that began to degrade his
reputation Lawless was one of the first
projects the actor landed after quitting
his most popular franchise in search of
more serious work Le Buff's so-called
method acting would be challenged by
co-star mia vashikovska Who described
his drunken Behavior as dangerous and
scary Le buff admitted to drinking
moonshine during production telling NY
Daily News Mia was ready to walk away
from the movie I was really pretty
aggressive about it and not into any
kind of weird strange way but I don't
think she had ever experienced anything
like that things got so out of hand that
director John hilcoat was forced to set
a firm boundary Le buff would not be
allowed to appear on set liquored up any
longer
the essential British comedy troupe
Monty Python developed quite a name for
themselves through the 1970s in most of
the 80s boasting multiple films and the
Beloved Monty Python's Flying Circus
television show the collective of
comedians is still celebrated today for
their delightfully warped utterly
distinct style of humor unfortunately
not everything was always on the bright
side of life for all the pythons the
2012 film a liar's autobiography is an
animated semi-biographical comedy about
the late python star Graham Chapman best
known for starring as King Arthur in
Monty Python and the Holy Grail and
Brian in the Life of Brian during the
feature Mania Chapman's former co-stars
and Friends openly speak about the
comedians over-the-top drinking
reportedly in the habit of finishing off
a bottle by 10 in the morning during a
particularly ruthless period Chapman
often caused performances and film
shootings to be canceled postponed or
worst of all fail still the movie is a
loving tribute to the late comedian
do you think
former child actor Lindsay Lohan is
Infamous for her fall from grace the
once big name actor faced a plague of
addictions criminal mishaps and a
tarnish reputation around Hollywood long
before she signed on to the portray the
lead role in the 2013 erotic Thriller
the Canyons the film had a minimal
budget but featured celebrated Talent
behind the cameras so it seemed like the
ideal make or break moment for Lohan's
career the film's director Paul Schrader
was quoted as saying we don't have to
save her we just have to get her through
three weeks in July ultimately Lohan
would show that three weeks could feel
like eternity as reported by the New
York Times the actor built a habit of
being inebriated on set showing up late
or not arriving at all nearly getting
herself fired from the project shortly
before it began most of the filming
ended up going on without too much
turbulence but three weeks was a long
stretch for Lohan the final days of
shooting are filled with rumors of drunk
driving falling over and an all-night
party with lady Gaga as you might
imagine Lohan's drinking caused many of
the scenes in the canyons to be unusable
and the movie was released to
unfavorable reviews if you or anyone you
know needs help with addiction issues
help is available visit the Substance
Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration website or contact
samhsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help 4357
foreign